“Ready up, squadron,” came the command
through the team’s headsets.
“Check your gear and prep for departure.”
Meyers started methodically securing the various
pouches of her assault vest, tightening the
straps of her tactical garb and making sure
she could quickly reach her spare ammo, just
in case the mission went sideways.
Beside her, the rest of the Deltas on the
team were doing the same, buckling into their
seats or checking their weapons were locked
and loaded.
Sat on the opposite side of the aircraft,
Cole had his helmet and mask off, loudly chewing
on gum with his mouth open, showing off the
disgusting contents.
When her eyes drifted over him, he tried to
give her a wink, resulting in Meyers rolling
her eyes.
“You know, you should really close your
mouth when you do that, Cole,” she said,
to which he sheered back at her.
“Your face looks like a clogged garbage
disposal.”
“Cut the chatter!”
Gamma Leader interrupted; they weren’t present
with the team, instead coordinating their
movements from the safety of an undisclosed
location through their headsets.
“Do I need to remind you that this isn’t
a field trip, Delta Unit?”
“Sir, no sir,” Meyers replied, gritting
her teeth.
“Good, now then, all of you listen up and
listen good,” the voice continued.
“This operation has been approved by The
Engineer himself, so let’s keep it quick,
clean, and quiet.
You all know your target: SCP-096.
You are to enter Site 19, capture the creature
and deliver it to our client, Valentin Zukovich,
at the rendezvous location.
The use of deadly force against Foundation
personnel is, as always, authorized.”
The team already knew all of this.
They’d been over it in their briefing before.
But the Insurgency demanded total efficiency
and zero ambiguity about the Delta’s objective.
“Now, each of you has been issued with a
pair of live feed goggles,” Gamma Leader
explained; as they described them, Meyers
and the other members of the team all produced
their goggles.
“As you know, these aren’t just relaying
your visuals to us here.
Your goggles have a camera lens at the front,
and will transmit that feed directly to your
eyes.
Given the nature of the SCP we’re going
after, the goggles have been programmed to
detect faces and pixelate them, so that should
circumvent any problems created by the creature’s
anomalous abilities.”
Meyers slipped her goggles over her eyes and
flipped the switch to activate them.
Immediately, her vision was filled with a
feed of Cole directly opposite her.
Only now, his entire face had been obscured,
replaced with a digital jumble of pixels.
It was exactly like the cop shows she used
to watch as a kid, how they would blur out
a suspect’s face to hide their identity.
Delta Meyers smirked, glad that she could
no longer see Cole’s face.
“Well, this is a definite improvement, Cole,”
she taunted.
“Now, I don’t have to look at you chewing
with your mouth open.”
“Another important reminder,” Gamma Leader
announced.
“Mister Zukovich is one of the Chaos Insurgency’s
wealthiest benefactors.
He’s not just offered us funding in exchange
for undertaking this mission, but if you pull
this off, he’ll grant us access to his fellow
oligarchs.
That means more people to offer potential
investment in the Insurgency.
So, remember, Delta Unit: we have a lot riding
on this.”
With that, the aircraft began to whirr into
life, lifting upwards off the ground.
The Insurgency had been developing this new
high-speed stealth craft for a while, a modified
troop carrier that was capable of both vertical
take-off and landing.
The technicians had boasted it could reach
supersonic flight speeds in seconds, effectively
launching Chaos Insurgents at enemy locations,
where they could be deployed, complete their
objective and escape in the craft all within
a matter of minutes.
“Oh, and one more thing,” Gamma Leader
stated as the stealth craft climbed higher.
“We have a contact within Site 19; Junior
Researcher Bartrum.
He’s agreed to let you in.
Of course, the last thing we want is the Foundation
squeezing any info out of him after you’ve
departed.
You know what to do.
Safe travels, Delta Unit.”
A building mechanical sound of rapid acceleration
filled the stealth craft, followed by a loud
boom as the engines kicked into gear.
Inside, Meyers and her fellow members of the
Chaos Insurgency – Deltas Griffith, Slater,
and Cole – all gripped their seats tightly
as they were rocked by the extreme force of
the craft’s speed.
It shot through the sky, hurtling towards
the coordinates of its target, reaching Mach
3 in a manner of seconds.
Outside the hull, a sonic boom rang out like
the foreboding sound of an ominous thundercrack.
Invisible to radar, sonar, and even protected
against most anomalous forms of detection,
the stealth craft zipped through the air,
gradually lowering its breakneck speed as
it came within several miles of Site 19.
Continuing its approach, the aircraft slowed
to a hovering stop above the Foundation facility.
Unbuckling from their seats, each of the Deltas
made their way to the ramp opening up at the
rear of the craft, and began to descend a
cable, lower and lower towards the roof.
Junior Researcher Bartrum had been pacing
nervously back and forth near the door that
led from the roof to a stairwell down into
Site 19.
He’d had to tell his fellow Foundation staff
that he needed a cigarette break, despite
not actually being a smoker.
As he waited for the Insurgency’s arrival,
he couldn’t stop himself from trembling,
only to turn and feel his heart jump in his
chest at the sight of the Delta Unit approaching
him.
“You Bartrum?”
Griffith asked.
“Y-yeah,” the researcher nodded awkwardly.
“We need your key-card,” the Delta stated.
“Oh, yeah.
Sure thing.”
Bartrum rummaged through his pockets, producing
his Foundation issue ID and handing it over.
It wasn’t until the card left his fingers
that a thought struck him.
“Wait, the security system logs where personnel
tap in their card.
If you use mine to spring 096, they’ll think
it was me who did it.”
“That’s the idea,” Slater replied apathetically
as Griffith raised his weapon and fired a
single, silenced shot.
After dragging Bartrum’s body away, the
team used his card to unlock the roof door
and make their way down the stairwell.
Each one of them knew the way, they had all
been to Site 19 plenty of times before back
in the day.
You see, of all things with an equal and opposite
reaction in the universe, the Foundation’s
was born out of their own organization.
The Chaos Insurgency had begun its life as
part of the SCP Foundation, an off-the-books
black ops unit created by the mysterious,
illusive O5 Council as a front to carry out
some of the organization's more nefarious
activities.
But the original Insurgency ultimately defected,
breaking away from the Foundation and becoming
a splinter group.
Their sole purpose was to eliminate their
rivals, the SCP Foundation, and they’d utilize
any means – even their own anomalies – to
achieve that goal.
Like many others within the Insurgency’s
ranks, Meyers, Griffith, Slater and Cole had
been scouted while they were still a part
of the Foundation.
Each of the Delta Unit had either formerly
been security personnel or a Mobile Task Force
operator, meaning they had skills that made
them useful to the Chaos Insurgency.
On top of that, they’d all become disillusioned
with Foundation.
Its constant secrecy and lies were frustrating
enough.
But their dangerous anomalous experiments,
all the deaths they had caused, directly or
indirectly, had highlighted something far
worse to the Deltas.
The Foundation placed more importance on the
containment in ‘SCP’ than protecting the
world.
Moving silently through the halls of Site
19, keeping their formation tight to cover
all angles in front and behind them.
Slater gave a hand signal, indicating they
were free to go ‘weapons hot’ if they
encountered any Foundation personnel on their
way towards their target.
Meyers still had her goggles active, even
though they hadn’t reached SCP-096’s cell
yet.
Even though she despised the Foundation and
what they had done, not being able to see
the faces of passing researchers and security
personnel made it a little easier to pull
the trigger.
The team approached the airtight steel cube
that housed their target.
All of the Deltas knew they needed to be quick;
while there were no recording or surveillance
devices inside the creature’s cell, it wouldn’t
take long for the Foundation to spot the trail
of bodies the team had left on their way down.
Griffith gave a nod for the others to activate
their goggles, his face already a scrambled,
pixelated blur from Meyers’s point of view.
Then, with a wave of the stolen key card,
the door to the cell opened.
As you may have already gathered, the goggles
being worn by the Deltas were actually based
on a pre-existing Foundation technology - The
infamous SCRAMBLE goggles brought to us by
the highly duplicitous Dr. Dan.
However, as anyone familiar with 096’s files
know, those goggles were imperfect creations,
and got a lot of MTF Operatives killed.
However, scientists paid off by the deep pockets
of Chaos Insurgency benefactors had worked
tirelessly on improving the technology, until
they finally made for a viable 096 protective
device.
Still, even with the goggles masking its haunting,
wide-jawed face, and even after Cole had gently
thrown a hood over the Shy Guy’s face, Meyers
couldn’t bring herself to look at it for
too long.
It felt wrong, like it was forbidden, despite
knowing it wouldn’t harm her or the other
Delta’s unless they looked directly at its
face.
SCP-096 was usually docile and calm when unobserved,
and while it didn’t seem to be anywhere
near as agitated as it got whenever its face
was seen, the towering creature was notably
confused as Slater looped a leash around its
neck and started guiding it out of the cell
with an animal control pole.
Suddenly, the alarms started blaring: the
Foundation knew they were there.
The Shy Guy still didn’t become enraged,
but began sobbing slightly underneath the
hood covering it.
“Move, move!”
Meyers shouted over the noise, as the Delta’s
started doubling back the way they had come.
Traversing the corridors back towards the
stairwell, any of the pixel-faced Foundation
staff that the Insurgents saw was quickly
dispatched, bullets being spat out of the
barrels of their weapons.
As the Delta’s reached the roof, the stealth
craft was waiting for them, as they quickly
boarded with SCP-096 in tow.
It sat at the far end of the craft, hunched
over itself, rocking back and forth slightly
as the troop carrier took off and shot towards
its next destination.
“Nice work, Delta Unit,” Gamma Leader
congratulated the team over their headsets.
“There’s been a slight change of plans.
Mister Zukovich has requested us to forego
meeting at the agreed rendezvous.
He wants you to bring SCP-096 to him directly.
He’s arriving at his compound as we speak.”
That was the part of the whole operation that
didn’t sit right with Meyers at all.
They had just risked their lives to secure
the Shy Guy, only to hand him over to some
wealthy oligarch.
It didn’t seem to make sense, or align with
the Insurgency’s goals.
“With respect, sir,” she spoke up.
“What benefit is this to us?
Why turn over the anomaly to Zukovich?
What does he want with it?”
“What Mister Zukovich wants is none of our
concern, Delta Meyers,” the mission co-ordinator
retorted abruptly.
“And as for the ‘why’, he’s worth
billions to us as a continued ally, so I’d
advise you to watch your tone unless-”
“Money?”
Meyers interrupted.
“Is that seriously the only reason we’re
doing this?
The Chaos Insurgency aren’t supposed to
be mercenaries!
We’re meant to be harming the Foundation,
using anomalies as tools to achieve that goal.”
There was a few long, awkward seconds of radio
silence, the other Delta’s staring uncertainly
at Meyers, too cowardly to speak up.
“You’re right,” Gamma Leader replied,
ending the uncomfortable pause; their tone
was an unnerving calm, like they were holding
back from letting loose in rage.
“Anomalies are useful tools for us achieving
what we need.
And right now, what the Insurgency needs is
to secure funding from Valentin Zukovich and
his fellow wealthy compatriots.
So, for the last time, deliver the package
as instructed.
Or face a reprimand.”
Arriving outside the compound, walls with
barbed wire at the top towering over their
stealth craft, the team marched towards the
front gate, guiding SCP-096 along by its neck.
The creature seemed to have calmed down, barely
making much in the way of noise, even with
the hood muffling it.
But that calm did little to settle the tension
Meyers still felt, and neither did the arrival
of Zukovich’s aide, coming out to lead the
Deltas into one of the many buildings of the
wealthy oligarch’s complex.
The doors to the building opened, and a cacophony
of noise came flooding out.
Screeching, roaring, howling, so loud it was
almost deafening.
Inside was like a zoo, or a zoo without enclosures.
All around, exotic animals were held in cramped
cages, empty of anything save for the wildlife
they house.
There were lions, tigers, bears – oh yes,
and many more besides.
Each one of them was illegally imported or
stolen, all now contributing to the exotic
menagerie of one Valentin Zukovich.
“Welcome, welcome, my friends!”
the billionaire greeted them eagerly, his
thick-accented voice booming, just audible
against the various animal noises.
“The operatives of the Chaos Insurgency
for you, sir,” the aide announced as he
gestured his hands towards the Delta Unit.
“Excellent, yes, yes, very good.
Get these hard-working people the case, Anatoly,”
Zukovich replied with a swat of his hand.
“Now, let me see what you have brought.
Let me look at my newest pet!”
“He wants it as a pet?”
Meyers heard Cole mutter next to her.
Zukovich looked at SCP-096 with wonder; it
was clear he had never seen a creature like
it, but had no doubt heard the stories of
what it could do.
Reaching out a hand, the wealthy oligarch
gently patted at the creature’s hairless
skin.
“So docile,” he remarked in surprise when
the Shy Guy did little to react.
“Why is has bag over head?”
A collective split second’s panic hit every
one of the Deltas as they watched Zukovich’s
hand reaching up to lift the hood from SCP-096’s
face.
It was Slater who reacted first, grabbing
the billionaire by the wrist, stopping him
before it was too late.
“Sorry, sir, but I don’t think that’s
an advisable idea,” he said, releasing the
man’s hand.
Zukovich paused for a second, an angered look
on his face.
Suddenly, he launched a fist at Slater, gripped
him by his uniform then struck again and again.
As their benefactor kept punching him, Slater
screamed in pain until he couldn’t anymore,
a sickening gurgle taking its place.
When he was finally released, he fell to the
floor, still.
“Is not ‘advisable idea’ to touch me
either,” Zukovich scoffed, spitting on Slater’s
body.
“We meant no disrespect, Mister Zukovich,”
Meyers spoke up.
“It’s just, you shouldn’t provoke it.
Anyone who looks at SCP-096 face… dies.”
The oligarch turned to face her; his anger
suddenly replaced worryingly fast with a look
of curiosity.
“Really?
Tell me, how they die?
Instant, like heart attack?” he asked, mimicking
a death rattle then chuckling.
“No, sir, it… finds them,” she replied.
“Reports differ, some indicate it kills
anyone that sees its face with its bare hands.
The exact method is unclear, because there
are never bodies.
It never leaves any trace.
If you see its face, it’ll annihilate you
completely.
That’s why they call it the Shy Guy.”
“Heh, ‘Shy Guy’.
I like this,” Zukovich laughed.
“It harder to kill from inside a cage.”
“I don’t think it matters.”
Meyer thought about shooting back with that,
but instead kept it in.
At that moment, Zukovich’s aide returned,
carrying a steel carry case.
He reached around it and unclipped the lid,
showing off rows of hundred dollar bills,
bound together in stacks.
“Fair day’s pay for fair day’s work,
yes?”
Zukovich announced.
As Cole went to collect the case, the aide
snapped it shut again.
“There is just one more favor I ask you
to do for me,” the oligarch announced.
“I host party tonight, big party!
I want to show off my new…
what you called it?
Shy Guy!
My friends are all very wealthy, could offer
money to your Insurgency.”
“With all due respect,” Meyers found herself
echoing the phrase for a second time that
day; without holding any respect for either
of the people it had been directed at.
“The Chaos Insurgency is not your private
security force.”
“Delta Meyers, quiet!”
Gamma Leader hissed in her earpiece.
“Zukovich’s connections could lead to
potentially billions – no, trillions – worth
of financial backing for the Insurgency.
You will do as he asks, or so help me, I’ll
kill you myself.”
A few hours after begrudgingly agreeing, Meyer
found herself standing in the menagerie room,
itching in the suit Zukovich’s staff had
instructed her and the other Deltas to wear.
All around her were more wealthy, corrupt
figures with close ties – and similarly
sized bank accounts – to Zukovich.
The guests were milling about, drinking flutes
of expensive champagne, observing the captive
animals up-close, or taunting them in their
cages.
In the center of the room, a new cage had
been placed with a shroud covering it and
SCP-096 inside.
“Friends!”
Zukovich announced, swaying slightly, evidently
drunk – as if the champagne bottle in his
hand wasn’t enough of a sign.
“Today is a great day!
Thanks to my friends in the Chaos Insurgency,
I am now the proud owner of a creature like
no other.”
He staggered towards the covered cage, gripping
the shroud covering it in his free hand, taking
another swig before he continued.
“I present to you: the Shy Guy!”
He pulled the cover away, met with a few scattered
sounds of confusion and surprise from his
rich guests.
Only one or two made frightened gasps at the
sight of what was within.
Sure enough, there, sitting timidly in its
cage, was SCP-096.
It was calm, its face still covered with the
hood.
“It’s just sitting there,” one of the
guests yelled.
“Hardly very impressive.”
“What does it do, Valentin?”
another of his wealthy compatriots asked.
“Well, it… ah, it mostly just sort of…
sits there,” Zukovich replied in his inebriated
state, before turning to look at the tall,
humanoid creature.
Suddenly, without warning and by force of
some intoxicated thought, he hurled his champagne
bottle at the creature.
“Do something!
Entertain my guests!” he yelled, slurring
his words.
The glass bottle hit SCP-096 and shattered.
Instantly, the creature recoiled, howling
in pain, met with more taunting laughter from
the gathered guests watching it.
It started shaking and sobbing heavily, weeping
loudly, which only elicited more laughs from
them all.
But Meyers and the other Deltas weren’t
laughing, instead looking in horror as SCP-096
drew itself up to its full, towering height…
and pulled off its hood.
It stared with sunken eyes at the crowd, their
taunts petering off and turning to silence
for a moment.
“Heh, not so shy now, yes?”
Zukovich laughed drunkenly.
Then in screamed.
SCP-096 went into a fit of rageful despair,
dashing through the bars of its cage and immediately
dispatching Zukovich.
The wealthy guests all began screaming in
horror at what was happening, as the Shy Guy
raced up to each of them one by one, killing
them all in a chain reaction for looking at
its face.
Meyers dashed for the exit; aware she didn’t
have her goggles to block the sight of the
creature’s wide-jawed, screaming expression.
Maybe if she could get far away, the stealth
craft could take her anywhere, maybe fast
enough to evade the Insurgency and SCP-096.
She thought the Shy Guy was too busy with
the assembled guests of the now-deceased Zukovich
and that would mean she could slip away unscathed.
It was only when she saw in appear in front
of her in the blink of an eye, screeching
in despair as it towered over Meyers, that
she realized she had thought wrong…
Now go check out “SCP-096 A LESSON IN POWER”
and “SCP-096 PICTURE PERFECT” for more
stories of everyone’s favorite homicidal
introvert!